but you know what is back this year got
a little twist on the world's largest
collector
car auction it's mecum auctions they're
all set up ready to go with
vintage motorcycles at the las vegas
convention
center wow look at that hector mejia is
there live
inside with all the details and hector
we want to see you rev one up over there
oh i wish i can hey there nate good
morning to you so the live auction kicks
off today
four straight days we have hundreds of
vintage motorcycles
we also have the newer custom
motorcycles and joining us live to talk
a bit about what they have here
we have dave major ceo of mecum auctions
good morning and welcome back
good morning we're just happy to be here
and ready to get started for the first
day here at mika motorcycle auction
what's changing this year well the only
real change that we have other than our
our extensive safety protocols is that
we're not able to invite the general
public
the observer to come so this auction is
limited to just registered bidders and
their
their guests as well so let's talk about
one or two of the motorcycles that are
here
going through the auction block later on
this morning starts what eight o'clock
eight am yeah it will open the doors at
8 o'clock the auction starts at 10
o'clock every day we'll run about 400
motorcycles across the block before we
finish each day
and of course at any mika motorcycle
auction you have the very rare
antique very unique and custom
and then we go to the one-of-a-kinds
kinds of motorcycles that you always see
to make a motorcycle auction
like the big john streamliner behind us
so this even though it looks like an
airplane is technically a motorcycle
is that right it's technically a
motorcycle because it's on two wheels
it was a bonneville salt flats eraser
this particular big john streamliner was
clocked at over
300 miles an hour on two wheels on the
bonneville salt flats in an unofficial
timing
wow so that's one of the things going
through the auction block today
you see very unique very unique items
here at meekum auction and that's
probably
in my opinion probably the most unique
motorcycle that's here at the auction
but of course
we have everything from the early 1900s
as i said rare motorcycles to things
like the big john streamliner that are
very unique dave thank you for having us
so we're going to go around and look
through some more gems
we'll highlight a few more motorcycles
in the next hour for now reporting live
hector mejia
eight news now back to you guys hector
thank you very much
some amazing machinery at the convention
center behind hector right there
motorcycle fans across the valley right
now their mouths are just like
shocking stuff yeah and there's quite a
bit of room there to go right around so